[Music]
all right let's go out to Dallas
Texas oh great probably another Rangers
Fan and talk to Steve hey Steve what's
up hey I was gonna say uh with the
Astros and the uh Patriots you know once
a cheater always a cheater I knew it I
knew
it we got our first our first title so
you know I'll give you this one it feels
good the first time doesn't it it's just
so exciting tell it was amazing it was
amazing and I lived in Houston for a
couple years so I I feel your love all
right I'm there AST Ru Astros rule all
right what's up Steve by the way Steve
you're a very smart human and I think
you're the
best thank you thank you and drugs right
I I just I to put it plainly I suck at
being married I'm on my third one um
it's on thin ice now we've been together
9 years and married almost five um
couple of things I have trouble working
together on projects that she thinks we
should like cleaning out the garage or
working on the barn taking care of the
lawn stuff like that um she wants to
help she asks me questions or make
suggestions or whatever and I I shrink
into myself I shut down I get short with
my answers and comments to her I
normally feel like I do best just figure
ing it out myself and doing doing it
that way um secondly I've hidden
purchases from her over the years um
I've had my family buy gifts for friends
with my own spending money but I haven't
told her about it tried to hide things
I've done from her uh for instance I
went I was going to go hunting and I
decided to go fishing instead and I
didn't tell her um until she found out
afterwards um I've also talked with my
brother about things that she does that
bothers me but I've exaggerated them and
I've not told the whole truth um or told
the entire story
accurately uh these Tendencies have
definitely increased over the past year
or two uh I feel controlled by her
discipline with money or or her
questioning me about things so I've
resorted to not sharing some things in
an effort to avoid her questioning me on
things um that's part of the problem I
feel like I have to ask permission for
some things that I really I really
normally shouldn't have to ask for um
obviously nothing justifies what I've
done but I feel controlled I feel like
these things eek out of me as a cry for
autonomy I definitely don't want to be
anonymous I just want some autonomy I
feel like I'm lacking
autonomy um she's found out about all of
these things she's so now she has of
course severe trust issues um she's
plainly stated that I'll never gain her
trust again which I understand
um definitely I can say that asking
forgiveness is not better than asking
for permission so there's no
justification for my actions but I do
feel like they're a reactive behavior
and I just don't know how
to um I guess stand up for myself on
some things that I feel like I should be
able to do or want to do without getting
pushed back and then it gets all jumbled
up and I just it turns into a
mess so sounds
like I mean you're you're taking full
ownership so I'm going to keep you at
your I'm going to hold you to your word
you're taking your ownership it sounds
like you've done some stupid stuff that
is is um I wouldn't advise anyone to do
it also sounds like you're married to a
brutal
person she's not brutal for sure she's
she's
just um let's do this let's I want I
want to Circle back you said you're not
good at being married are these the same
patterns that showed up in marriage one
and two why did those marriages fall
apart um first one I felt I was too
controlling in the relationship and um
it was not really sure why it fell apart
I know that I I had Parts I was I was
just too controlling over stupid little
things like hanging your towel and rack
and stuff like that um and she left you
she did okay yep all right the
second one was only six months it's a
long story but it just it shouldn't have
happened in the first place
um I don't know how to really describe
that but it it wasn't a match from the
beginning okay the hard the hard part
that one the hard part about what you
just described with your current Wedding
Marriage not wedding but your current
marriage is it's really tough to chicken
or
eggot has she found herself increasingly
more controlling and paying attention to
everything in really trying to hem you
in because you're just a dude who just
is dishonest and you just kind of do
your own life and you don't want anyone
you you kind of want a a wife but you
don't you want the idea of a wife but
you don't want to do the work that it
takes to have a real wife and she is
clinging so tightly to just shreds of of
of intimacy and relationship that you're
starting to get choked by it
or man you've really worked hard yeah
you've been a knucklehead but for crying
out loud I'm going hunting and so now
I'm going fishing it's not I don't know
that there needs to be a big Public
Announcement but then she here comes the
Grinch and she is yelling I can't
believe you lied to me and you're like
dude it doesn't it's it's it's fish not
Birds right or fish not deer what's the
big deal so what do you think is what do
you think it is I go back and forth on
it and
um it's I think obviously a little bit
of both um
I felt probably a little constricted and
then just or just wanted to do my own
thing and then she found out about that
and then it's gotten probably Tighter
and then I've reacted
more uh you know in response to that
over the years lately she she's
definitely she's got her radar on which
I know is what you've said you know the
radar is a is her radar is working
perfectly
um so she's hyper sensitive or you know
on the lookout for things that makes me
want to just do more things that and you
know so yeah I feel so part of it is I
feel he's gonna have an issue with
something so I just like the fishing
instead of hunting and
um it was it just so I just went and did
it and then she found out later so I
want to share those things with her but
but I feel like everything a lot of
things are kind of a bigger production
all right so why why have you never said
that exact
sentence because I hunt I hunt a lot and
I'm trying to think if I told my wife
hey we're heading out to go hunting
tomorrow morning and I leave way before
she I leave like at 4 in the morning so
I head out and I get to where we're
going and one of my buddies shows up and
he's like dude let's go fishing and I'm
like no and he talks me into
it right I can't imagine that would feel
this big be feel compelled I might text
my wife when I knew she was awake just
in case something happened she would
know I'm on a lake somewhere but like we
have that trust established that she'd
be like I don't I mean you're not here I
don't care what you're doing you see
what I'm saying right so why haven't you
s I'm trying to even make that a big
deal in my house and it's just not but
why haven't you sat down and said hey I
want to bring you into my life but I
can't or we have wasn't uh I don't feel
there was a big resolution on it but we
I that was our latest conversation was I
want to share these things with her but
I don't feel that I can sometimes but
can you not because she is an
overbearing
nag it's her way for sure is that is
that true or is it because you don't
want to you don't want to do marriage
with somebody you just want your own
life you don't want anyone to tell you
how to do the yard you don't want to
tell you when to do the yard you don't
anyone to tell you about your clothes
your life your house anything thing I
want the towel hung up where I want it
hung up I want everything to be the way
it is and what you're looking for
actually is you want a maid you want you
want an
employee no not that for sure okay then
what is it man because here's the deal
at the end of the day y'all are choosing
this misery that you
have right both of y'all are making
choices for everything in your life to
suck and I I can't wrap my head around
why you're choosing
this we
are ordinarily we have this amazing
connected relationship we even share the
same pillow we're and like that's around
us I'm just kidding I figured you'd say
that we travel with one pillow and we
share it and we're we are like siamese
twins when we sleep it's just okay so
why do you lie about your wife to your
brother I felt more and more stifled
about I don't give a crap about that I
don't care how you felt why did you
your wife to your brother I know it's
that's that's the scum part that I've
done just answer the question though yo
are you trying to are you trying to like
distance yourself from your wife are you
trying to be cool in front of your
brother like why did you
lie about your wife to your
brother um what did that get
you
nothing it got her angry at me why did
you hide purchases why did you like in
my world I call that Financial
infidelity why' you cheat on your on
your wife when it comes to
money even routing even laundering money
through family members to buy things for
other people yeah I don't have an excuse
for
it so your wife's not here I think that
you're covering up for in a pretty noble
way but she sounds like she's tough on
you so but she I can't talk to her she's
she's not here right what I'm G to tell
different go ahead sorry yeah we just
have we have some different views on
money um what is your view on money you
should be able to spend it whenever you
want whatever you want because it's
yours no no no no no not at all our
money's combined we get a little bit of
spending money each month for each other
um
that's supposed to be fun play
unaccountable money
um and most time it is is I think she's
I think she wonders what I spend it on
um so Steve are you seeing somebody else
no not a chance not a chance not the
more I'm the more you're talking the
more I'm thinking the more there
something something feels off I feel
like I'm missing a piece of a puzzle
here no there's absolutely zero no not
even in the same universe okay promise
you on that okay I just like to go I
feel like if I went and bought um lunch
for myself out she's wondering what I
did for lunch and I didn't save the
receipt for our taxes and so it's still
accountable I feel like I just want to
go get some lunch is it because she
loves
you is that her way of trying to connect
with you hey man what you have for lunch
today yeah it is for sure and then for
some reason I feel like she's keeping
tabs on me I have a thing about that she
is she I don't think so
okay then here's the I really don't
think so then here's the deal you have
to decide because the things you've told
me can be one of two things and I'm just
being honest and it's hard in this short
of a conversation especially without her
if you ever want to call back with her
on the phone that would be fun man but
here's the deal
either she is borderline
pathological she's like the Deep State
she wants to know what you a eat where
you are at all times she wants to know
what you spend and why you spent it and
who you spent it with and you can't have
a marriage like that unless you are
somebody cheated on somebody and you are
creating a you are reestablishing trust
and then for a season you have to live
like that sure right either that's the
case or there is a woman who is
desperately she is so desperately trying
to connect with you she ask you about
lawn care for God's
sakes and you're just like leave me
alone lady what' you have for lunch
today my God will you quit hassling
me well hey I'll do the taxes did you
get the receipt oh my and bro
why that's what I was hoping to get help
with I don't know why I have this uh
that's why you're the one I she's not a
nag she cares about me we care deeply
about each other but I I just I resist
some things and I don't know
why why do you hate
Steve I don't know you can't stand
Steve and if Steve gets brought out of a
shadow at any at any level from what
Steve had for
lunch for who Steve dated in high school
to what Steve thinking Steve feels buck
naked in Time Square totally exposed and
terrified and he lashes out or he goes
undercover to keep Steve from being seen
because Steve doesn't want anyone to see
Steve because Steve doesn't like
Steve true or
false they're
um do you struggle with
pornography no no what's your
viice my vice is uh well I like to buy
things how much have you bought that she
doesn't know
about that she doesn't know about
nothing she knows about
everything
okay here's the deal I love you enough
to tell you this brother this ends in
divorce unless you decide that you're
worth being in a relationship
with
period and that means you have to let
some people connect with
you and if something
like um my
goodness when I used to do a lot of
crisis response stuff I was showing up
to to people's homes and there was dead
bodies there was body parts there were
brains all over the place and my wife
tried to connect with me and I finally
said hey you don't want to know what I'm
seeing at
night so I don't and I don't feel
comfortable talking about it but I will
tell you last night was a really rough
one and when I say that it would really
mean a lot to me if you just give me a
hug or one night after I had to show up
and there was some kids that had passed
away it was a real gnarly situation I
woke up I went in my kids' room and
Hank's room he was really young and I
just held him and he was dead asleep and
then I come out of his room and it was
like in the middle of the night I said
to I had to hold my
son the next morning my wife was like
man were you in the what were you doing
and I was like hey you know I don't want
to talk about so there's that if you
feel that strongly about the yard hey
this is my Sacred Space and I know it's
so weird but I feel awward talking about
the
yart be honest and be brave enough be a
man enough to say here's what I
need but it's just cruel to beat up
somebody for for wanting to connect with
the man that she said she
loves especially if the only reason he
doesn't want to connect is because he
doesn't love
himself
right do you believe you're worth being
loved
man
sometimes I think you
are here's a here's I mean here's my
path forward for you man and I know this
is brief you and I could probably talk
for another couple hours and I'd love
just to go have a drink with you one day
um
I get a sense from you that it is
exhausting to be
you that's how much grief you carry
about you how much
disdain and you have to hear me say my
friend please I know we're on the phone
and you can't see me please listen to
this your wife is trying to love you and
you're worth that love love
period any story countered to that is
not
true it's a
lie and so the goal here is to stop
running from that woman loves me and to
start leaning into okay I'm going to
practice being uncomfortable in her
presence I'm going tell her that I love
you so much and every time you try to
connect with me my body screams you're
not worth
her and it has to stop now and that's
nothing she's going to have to fix
you're going to have to be the guy that
says I am going to allow myself to be
seen and that's going to start with you
keeping a Daily Journal
practice that's going to be you deciding
on a weekly basis to sit with your wife
and say how can I love you this
week that's going to be you deciding to
go see a counselor because you have to
go seek some professional help for this
period dude period stay on theine I'll
get you three free months with my
friends at better help I'm I'll at least
get you going you can start seeing
somebody over the next 24 48
hours but it sounds to me like your wife
is desperate and she's getting to the
end of her rope she's saying dude I've
been trying to connect with you for so
long and I'm tired of going to war and
get my hand bit off every time I reach
out to hold
yours you have to decide to enter into a
season of discomfort where you learn to
love yourself where you learn learn what
it feels like to be loved from someone
else when you learn to drop your
shoulders and say I don't care how the
Yard Works cuz that's my
wife I don't care where my towels are
today that's my
wife and then in those moments that you
do need something you don't say you need
to do this you say hey
um when I go to lunch I don't think it
through I just order like a sandwich or
whatever I don't pay attention and when
I get home for some reason it feels like
I'm being attacked I feel attacked I'm
working on
that but I promise if I don't know what
I had for lunch and I didn't keep the
receipt I'm I'm not I mean I'm not
trying to hide anything from you I love
you I just don't think through lunch
that much but I can't wait for
dinner I feel like this one's gonna
gonna be a long time working through
Steve you call me anytime and we'll get
you back on the show man but those are a
few steps you can get going hang on the
line we'll hook you up with better help
and I'll hook you up with building a
non-anxious life my latest book give you
a place to
start